it's so good and everybody told me not
to do it everybody said why are you
doing this this is ambitious you're
gonna you can't it's too much all this
stuff and i was like this song is so
good i'm gonna have a hit song that's
what i kept saying i'm gonna have a hit
song and it's been a long time since
i've had a big stinking hit and this
song deserves
the vehicle of this music video it is
it's so good
but of course their baby announcement
pays tribute to michael's 2009 hit
haven't met you yet and only we were on
set while michael gushed about his then
girlfriend lou your girlfriend's in the
music video
how fun is that it was so much fun
what's weird is that um
i mean the song was inspired by her so
and it was and she's a great actor the
happy couple have been married since
2011 and have three beautiful kids but
they've certainly experienced their fair
share of ups and downs i thought my wife
was the most beautiful woman i'd ever
seen in my life but i didn't know her i
was infatuated by her and then we got
married and even then
it was still pretty early i mean
many times i'm sure both of us looked at
each other and thought
you know
it was just the right thing and
and then we have our first child and
and our second
and then when that thing happened with
noah
and we found out
who we had really married
i think that's when we fell in love
back in 2016 their son noah was
diagnosed with liver cancer say hello
e.t canada hello
e.t canada
canada
my wife and i and our family don't know
that people will ever understand that we
know we're not the only family that's
gone through hard things and uh not only
did we we know that there were people
that were sending us messages of love
that there were people
in their churches and synagogues and
temples all over the world praying for
us
you know i want other
[Music]
other parents to know that there's
there's hope and then
even when there's
not
somehow it's going to be okay
thankfully noah is now in remission you
know what when the poop hits the fan you
find out who you're dealing with
absolutely and i think
i think both of us you know
looked at each other and went wow this
was we got really lucky here i think
you're right when life does what it does
and you have something where you both
either dig in or you get out which is
what a lot of couples do right
that's where you either fall back in
love and you really go for it
or
circumstances break you up it's been
something it's been quite a journey and
i'm a i'm a big fan
would you ever consider doing a duet
with lou maybe one day i don't i don't
know whatever i do with her i want it to
be
organic
[Music]
you